[Music]
do you remember the first time a horror
movie villain
really terrified you it probably had a
lot to do with a truly terrifying
disguise
so let's go down the memory lane of our
nightmares and explore the best
disguises in horror movie history
the title of the 1996 movie scream and
its infamous ghostface mask
are both references to edvard monk's
1893 painting known as the screen
which depicts the panic and anxiety of
human existence
as monk wrote in his diary inspiration
for the piece came to him one day when
the blood red splash of the setting sun
onto the clouds gave him the sense of an
unending scream
passing through the world considering
all that it would be strange if the
painting didn't go on to inspire a
halloween costume
sure enough scream director wes craven
discovered the ghost face mask
after it had been released as a
halloween costume this mask helped
disguise the fact that the killer was
actually two people working together to
take revenge on sidney prescott's mother
the existentialist philosophy that the
scream painting is often associated with
points towards there being no inherent
meaning in life this in turn means that
people
can and must create their own purpose
which plays into the villain's
motivations in the film
mrs prescott's affair tore billy
loomis's family apart
and sucked the meaning from his life
thereby compelling him to put
new meaning into his life via his
violent quest for revenge
what's the matter sydney you look like
you've seen a ghost
director kevin smith's shocking 2014
film tusk
isn't the most well-known horror movie
but it's nevertheless made an indelible
mark on the genre
this movie's disguise is unique in that
it's not worn by the killer but instead
imposed upon the victim worse yet it's
constructed from the skin of the victim
himself
the plot follows justin long as wallace
who encounters howard an eccentric
wheelchair-bound old man
who lives in the middle of nowhere
howard severs parts of wallace's limbs
and re-stitches his skin to form a
walrus suit which includes tusks
made out of tibia bones so why did
howard choose this particular aquatic
mammal
it turns out that he once survived the
shipwreck with the aid of a walrus who
rescued him and pulled him to safety on
the rocks
but he remained stranded for so long
that he eventually had to eat his savior
and companion
since then he's attempted to recreate mr
tusk
multiple times hoping secretly that one
of them will have the fortitude to kill
him
and do justice to the memory of the
friend he betrayed
the sacrificial garb in 2019's
mid-summer
is another example of an intensely
symbolic disguise
that's forced upon the victim the film
chronicles the pagan rituals that take
place at a festival celebrated by a
swedish cult once every 90 years
the plot begins with a group of students
responding excitedly to
their swedish friend powell's invitation
to the festival
but he's luring them to be part of the
ritual which will lead to some of them
dying
dany as played by florence pew wins a
maypole dance competition
and is crowned the may queen that title
grants her the responsibility of
choosing the final sacrifice of the
festival
who will be put into a disemboweled bear
suit she selects christian her
emotionally distant and unfaithful
boyfriend
in norse mythology the bear symbolizes
the kind of strength and healing that
brings balance to the human and
spiritual world
which is what the sacrifice of christian
in the bear suit is supposed to
accomplish
donning costumes was a symbol of power
in viking culture
but christian is the opposite of a god
and leader so in a fascinating inversion
the bear suit serves as the vessel of
his destruction
pennywise the dancing clown's appearance
isn't a disguise in the traditional
sense
like you would see a human killer donna
disguise to mask their identity
rather it's a symbolic form taken on by
an ethereal force of evil in order to
lure people in
and prey upon their fears the clown
manifestation is one of many that this
ancient entity has assumed over the
course of centuries to prey upon the
children of derry maine
every 27 years author stephen king chose
the form of the clown
after asking himself what scared
children more than anything else in the
world
the fear of children was central because
one of the entities main powers is its
ability to go
undetected by adults the killer clown
sewer habitat meanwhile was inspired by
the goat who dwells under a bridge in
the three billy goats gruff fairy tale
in just about every way the pennywise
disguise represents a villain designed
specifically for targeting children
popcorn is that your favorite uh-huh
well i do hockey is a pretty violent
sport
though not quite as violent as serial
killing nonetheless
the sport's traditional goalie mask is
inextricably linked with one of the
greatest horror movie villains of all
time
the world first met jason voorhees in
1980s friday the 13th but it actually
wasn't until 1982's friday the 13th part
3
that his trademark mask first came into
the picture
courtesy of jason victim shelly
previously
jason wore a burlap sack with one left
eye hole to hide his face
jason will go on to wear the mask until
his supposed death via bludgeoning from
a kid named tommy in the 4th
friday the 13th film but even after
getting hacked up with a machete and
buried
the legacy of his mask lived on a
similar mask is worn by his copycat
killer roy burns in the next film
also tommy has a nervous breakdown and
nearly becomes a copycat killer himself
while donning a similar hockey mask
following this in the sixth film tommy
goes to make sure
jason is dead throws the mask on his
grave and accidentally revives the
killer through lightning
jason then stumbles his way through
movie after movie
as his mask gets increasingly beaten up
halloween's michael myers is meant to be
seen as the incarnation of pure evil
which isn't exactly a compliment to
william shatner whose face inspired the
mask that the killer wears
it was all a matter of budget or lack
thereof
the first halloween didn't have a whole
lot of money on hand so the mask was
just something bought from a local
costume shop for amiga dollar 98
this hasty solution worked great at
first but it created some difficulties
for the sequel
rick sternbach worked as an illustrator
on a number of star trek franchise
projects as well as on halloween too
he could only find one mask from the
original film and no one had any clue
where to get more
luckily he discovered a serial number
etched into the neck area of the mask
along with the name of the vendor don
pose studios
a quick phone call later and it turned
out to be their captain kirk mask
in exchange for credit don post sent
over a whole box
the creepy mask now remains an icon even
if it still doesn't really look all that
much like shatner
leatherface was first introduced to
moviegoers in 1974's texas chainsaw
massacre
he's a cannibal who wears a mask made
from his victim's skin
more than almost any other cinematic
killer leatherface's different masks
expose a lot about his psyche and
desires they even arguably create them
this is perhaps why he's garnered
empathy from some viewers
as he seems to simply be a large child
acting completely at the whims of his
family
one way or another leatherface's
personality is externally determined in
nearly every instance
his killing mask is worn while capturing
and dispatching people
but he also has an old lady mask and a
pretty woman mask
which facilitate his respective desires
to honor his country upbringing by
dressing up and being domestic caring
and helpful
the most significant aspect of
leatherface's habit is that the masks
themselves
are arguably the only way he exhibits
any sense of personality
the only thing they obscure is emptiness
over the course of the saw series we get
multiple looks at the actual
face of jigsaw killer john kramer but we
also see him in a pig mask
which is first introduced in the 2004
original
as a detail that one of his victims
recalls later in the series the mask is
revealed to be a tribute to the year of
the pig
during which jigsaw began his work in
chinese zodiac legend
the pig can symbolize laziness the
antithesis of the will to live that john
attempts to divine in each of his test
subjects
the pig is also the final animal of the
zodiac cycle which can be read as a
symbol of john's cancer diagnosis
with his serial killing being the final
chapter of his life
a pig mask containing a chloroform rag
was the first tool that john
ever used to subdue a test subject he
chose it personally as a representation
of his pessimistic worldview
and the slow decay of his body from
cancer however the pig
also represents rebirth which does
require a death
so while it may appear paradoxical at
first it actually makes sense to read
the pig
as a symbol of both beginning and ending
this squares up with jigsaw's motivation
and tactics despite the frequent deaths
of his subjects
he genuinely does want to give them a
second chance at life
the cast of the killers in 2011's you're
next
are credited by both the names of the
human characters they play
as well as the name of the animal masks
they wear the crew includes a lamb
a tiger and a fox behind the mask though
lamb and tiger are brothers and
represent just about the only instance
of familial loyalty in the film
two other brothers felix and crispin
turn out to be in on a plot to massacre
their own family
in order to collect an inheritance
animal masks
are the perfect representation of a home
invasion in which some wild and
destructive force from the outside
threatens the balance within the home
you might expect a wolf to be among this
invasive animal cohort
but it's nowhere to be seen but perhaps
we do see a wolf after all
eren crispin's girlfriend has her own
primal roots having grown up on a
survivalist compound
this is something none of the
conspirators anticipate and she takes
them all down
one by one surviving on her own strength
as a lone wolf
where's felix
i stuck a blender in his head and killed
him psycho's norman bates
doesn't wear a mask but he doesn't need
to for one of the most shocking
disguises in horror movie history
when he kills he dresses up as his
mother which is about as creepy as it
gets
both baits and leatherface are loosely
based on real-life serial killer ed
gain also known as the plain-filled
butcher gaine had dissociative episodes
when he dug up corpses from local
graveyards
which echoes norman's struggle with
dissociative identity disorder
meanwhile in psycho norman's effort
stopped at the point of only just
wearing his mother's clothes
his psychology is nevertheless quite
similar to gaines
as all of norman's killings revolve
around his mother
his first victims are his mom and her
lover whom he kills out of jealousy
a boy's best friend is his mother after
his trauma he develops dissociative
identity disorder
taking on his mother's personality at
times to escape his own guilt and to
kill anyone he'd think she would want
dead if she were alive
this also absolves him of guilt for any
other killings in his mind
ultimately the disguise is a coping
mechanism in response to the loss of the
most important person in his life
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one